MINE CETINKAYA-RUNDEL: Hi, my
name is Mine Cetinkaya-Rundel
and I am a Developer
Educator at Posit,
as well as a Professor of the
Practice at Duke University.
And in this video, I'd like
to introduce you to Quarto.
So if you've been hearing
a lot about Quarto
and wanting to dive in
and have been waiting
to see when is the
right time for me,
or if you've played
with it a little bit
and want to get a sense
of what more I can do
and what more you
can do with it,
hopefully, this will be a
good introduction for you.
So we are going to start
things pretty simply.
We're going to start with
a single Quarto document.
I am going to open
that up in RStudio.
So let's go ahead
and open that up.
My Quarto document
is called index.qmd.
For those of you who are
familiar with R Markdown,
you're probably familiar with
file suffixes called rmd.
And Quarto documents
are called qmd.
At the top of this
document, things
should look pretty familiar.
We have a YAML with some
metadata about our document--
a title, the format that
we want to output to.
So we're going to make
an HTML document first.
And I'm going to use the
RStudio visual editor.
So again, if you are
familiar with R Markdown
and haven't played with
RStudio visual editor lately,
you can switch over
to the source editor,
and things should look
pretty familiar to you.
But let's go back to the visual
editor where you get a document
that feels a bit more like
Google Docs or writing
in an app-like notion where
things are a little bit more
what-you-see-is-what-you-get.
For example, I have some
information about the data set
I'm going to use here--
the Penguins data set from
the palmerpenguins package--
and I might want to bold
the name of the package.
And I can do that by
using the toolbar here
or I can use keyboard
shortcuts to do that as well.
The visual editor has other
handy tools on the toolbar.
For example, I can directly
add a link to this.
So let's go ahead and add a link
to the palmerpenguins website.
And hit OK.
So that now is a live link.
And if we were to switch over
back to the source editor,
if you are familiar with
writing things in Markdown,
you can see that
under the hood, it is
writing the Markdown for you.
It's just that you
are not the one
having to write the Markdown.
So let's go ahead and
render this document
and let's see what
it looks like.
A setting that I like
to use on my RStudio IDE
is I generally like to preview
my documents in the viewer pane
so that I can see my source
code on one side and my render
document on the other side.
So we should be able to see
our render document here
in the viewer pane on the
right-hand side of our RStudio
IDE.
Things will look pretty similar
between the source document
and the render document because
our source document is also
using this visual format.
But the difference is
that on the source side,
we only have the code,
and on the output side,
we're seeing the code and the
output to go along with it.
So let's introduce you to a
few of Quarto's features now.
We can see that we are taking a
look at the palmerpenguins data
set, and we have our
visualizations here for it.
But we might want to take a
look at the actual data itself.
So I am going to go ahead
and insert a code chunk here,
which I can do either with the
Insert, Code Chunk menu here
or using my keyboard shortcut
with the forward slash
and bringing up the
Insert Anything toolbar.
And I'll say I want
an R Code Chunk.
And let's say that I want to
glimpse at the penguins data
set.
And let's go ahead and
Render that document
and we'll be able to see
the input and the output
on the viewer side.
Scrolling down on
this document, I
have a code chunk
that generates a plot.
So one thing that
I might want to do
is add an alternative text
to this figure, for example.
And I can do that by using
the fig-alt chunk option.
The visual editor nicely
does YAML completion for me
so I can choose from here which
chunk option I want to use.
I'm going to go with fig-alt.
And I have a
multi-line chunk option
so I'm going to use
this vertical bar here.
I've already
written the alt text
so I will just copy and
paste that here so you don't
have to watch me type this out.
But basically, we're
saying that this
is a scatterplot of penguins'
bill depth and length colored
by species.
And we say something
about the trend we see.
It's relatively strong,
and a linear association.
Let's go ahead and
Render this document.
And when we Render the
document, the alternative text
won't show on the output,
because again, it's
not part of the
output necessarily
but the underlying source code.
But if I pop this out
to a browser window
and scroll down to my
figure and right-click on it
to inspect it
I should be able to see that
the alt text is actually
available for me under the hood.
If I'm writing a report, I might
want to not necessarily show
all of this code on the output.
So one thing I can do is
I can hide the code one
chunk at a time with another
chunk option, echo: false,
and that will only hide
that particular chunk
option, that particular
code chunk's code.
But if I want to do that
at the document level,
I have a few options as well.
I can actually go to the
YAML on top of my document.
And under execute, I can say
I want to do echo: false.
And let's go ahead and
Render this full document.
And we will see that all
of the code is now hidden
and we only have
the output, which
might be preferable for you
depending on your audience,
whether you want them
to see the code or not.
And here we go.
Here is our output
without any of the code.
Over here, we have
a figure that's
being generated with code.
And in the text, I have said
the figure below is a bar--
is actually a scatterplot.
Let's go ahead and fix that
That scatterplot of
species of penguins.
We can add
cross-references to this.
So, in order to add
a cross-reference,
I need to do two things.
First, I need to
change my chunk label
to include the word fig at
the beginning as a suffix.
So that's fig dash.
And second, I need
to add a caption.
So to add a caption, I
will use the fig-cap.
And maybe let's go ahead
and re-use this information
from here.
All right, so now I
have a figure that has--
a label that starts
with fig and a caption.
All right, so let's
highlight this,
and let's say we want to
Insert a Cross Reference.
The figure is available
for me to choose here.
And if I Render the
document one more time,
it will create a link
to the figure itself.
So now I don't need
to worry about when
I render my document, if it's
below or above, particularly
if I'm outputting to
something like PDF.
I can do the same thing
with tables as well.
The only difference
is that I would
need to add the tbl
for table suffix.
And similarly, I need to
add a caption for that too.
So this will be, let's
say, the first 10 penguins.
And let's go ahead and do this
without using the Insert menu.
I can simply grab
the label and I
can say-- instead
of the table below,
at and the name of my table.
And I can Render my document.
And it will do the counting
and the labeling of my figures
and tables for me.
So I have a figure
1 here and then
a table that's going to be
cross-referenced underneath it
as well.
And voila, here we go.
We also have a Table 1.
The last thing I'd like to
show in the visual editor
is adding citations, which can
be a huge hassle sometimes.
So here we are going to cite
where these data come from.
So in order to do
that, I'm going
to say I want to
Insert a Citation.
And you can see that I have some
options to choose from in terms
of where my citations
can come, but I
am going to go ahead and
grab the DOI of the paper
where the palmerpenguins data
were originally published.
And I can say that I
want to Insert this.
And when I do so,
two things happen.
Reference gets added here.
And you can see that my
YAML already also gained
a new line called bibliography.
And if I go to my
files, I have actually
gained that file
called references.bib.
And in this file is the bib
reference for this paper.
So if we go ahead and
Render this document,
we will see that the
reference has been added.
If I hover over
it, I can see it.
Or if I click on
it, it will take me
to the end of my document
where I have a section called
References inserted for me.
So we've talked about creating
a single document with Quarto.
And this has been a
HTML document so far.
If I want to change the output
to something like a PDF,
all I need to do is
indicate that on my YAML.
So let's go ahead and
give that a Render too.
I don't need to change
anything in terms
of the syntax in my document.
Right.
Now we have a PDF document
with the same content,
also hiding the code.
So respecting the YAML options
that we had indicated earlier.
And the nice thing
about this PDF document
is not only was I able
to obtain it so easily,
but it also shows up in
my Viewer tab as opposed
to a pop-up window.
Now let's go ahead and
change things up even more.
We've gone from a
single HTML document
to a single PDF document.
What about making slides?
So I'm going to make
HTML-based slides using
our revealjs as my output.
And once again, I am not
going to touch anything
in my document.
The only thing
RStudio asks me to do
is to reload the
visual editor when
I change the output format.
And let's go ahead and
Render that as well.
And here we go.
Our document title
is now a title slide.
I can actually scroll
through the different slides
that I have.
Each of them are determined
by these headings.
So let's go ahead and
actually turn this
into a slightly more
reasonable slide deck now.
Things worked but my text
is a little bit squished.
I am going to take a
look at the Outline view
here, where I can see
the different sections
in my document.
And I'm going to make these
second-level headings.
So these particular Data,
Species, and Penguins
are going to be
second-level headings.
And let's go ahead and insert
some first-level headings
as well using the
Insert Anything tool.
We'll say that I want
a first-level heading.
Maybe first, I want
something like Introduction.
And then at the end, I might
want something like Analysis.
And maybe a slide
here, something
like Modeling results.
And then I might finally
want another slide
at the end called References.
Remember those
references that I had,
I might want to move
them to the very end.
So I've created this
hierarchical structure
for my document
that I can nicely
view here in the outline.
And if I Render my
document, I should
be able to see that that same
outline is apparent in my slide
deck as well.
My first-level
headings are going
to turn into section
dividers in my slides.
And then my
second-level headings
are going to turn into
indicators for a new slide.
So we can see that
same outline here.
And I can go ahead and
scroll through my slides.
Some things that I'm seeing
here, for this data slide,
things look a little too big.
Maybe things are not filling in.
So using the visual editor,
I can start tweaking things.
I can write full-on
CSS for my slides,
but I can also use some
of the predefined classes.
So one of my favorite is the
smaller class, for example.
So let's go ahead and
do that and Render that.
And that should squish my text,
make it a little bit smaller,
allowing me to fit a bit
more text into my slides.
Never a great idea to
put a lot of text on your
slides, but if you're
in a pinch and you just
want things to be a little bit
smaller so everything fits,
this is a really nice fix.
Let's also go ahead and
get rid of this option.
Or actually, let's go
ahead and say that I
do want the code to be shown.
So I'm going to say echo: true.
So let's say I'm
teaching, and I actually
want to show the code as well.
We'll see that our
slides get busy
again because we have both
the code and the output
on one slide.
This one looks pretty
fine, but over here, we're
seeing that the figure is
squished in order to make room
for the code.
Well, we have a remedy
for that as well.
What I'm going to say is
for this particular slide
and this code chunk, I
want the output location
to be, let's say,
column-fragment
and see what that gets us.
So what this is going
to do is put my code
in one column of my slides and
my output in the other column
of my slides.
But it will actually add some
sort of animation to my slides
and delay the output.
So I might get
something like this
where when I move to the next
slide, I can see the code.
This still looks
pretty squished so
if I don't want that, I can
choose a different option once
again using the YAML
completion with my tab.
And I might say, OK, just move
it to the next slide for me.
So the plot moves
to the next slide.
So we've made a single
document so far.
And we have made
also a slide deck.
Now let's imagine
a situation where
you have multiple
documents, a project,
and you want to put them
all together in something
like a website.
So what we're going to do is--
let's go back and change
the format to HTML again.
Reload our visual editor
and Render this document
as a single HTML document.
And let's go ahead and
add one more document,
maybe something
that says "about,"
something like an About page.
For our web page, I'm going to
create a new document called
About, probably has some
boilerplate, our language here.
Maybe let's go ahead
and select all of that
and delete it and say,
this is a demo website.
And I'm going to save
this file as about.qmd.
And now I have two
documents, two qmd documents
in my project.
An about.qmd and an index.qmd.
And I have their
outputs as well.
Let's go ahead and
clear those out,
those outputs so that I have
just my source files here.
To bring these two together
in a website format,
I just need one file,
plain text file,
specifically called underscore
quarto dot YAML, dot Y-M-L.
And in here, I need to
actually tell Quarto
how to bring things together.
So I want a Quarto project.
I want the type of this
project to be website.
Note that I'm not
even typing these.
I'm using the YAML completion.
And in this website,
I want the title
of my website to be
perhaps, welcome to Quarto.
And I want a navbar.
Let's say that on
the left, I would
like to link to my index.qmd
file and my about.qmd file.
And let's go ahead
and save this.
And I am going to just relaunch
this project from the project
navigator in RStudio.
And once I relaunch
this project,
we can see that I gained
a new tab called Build.
And let's go ahead
in this new Build
tab, click on Render Website.
And voila, I have a website.
Let's pop this out
to a browser window
so we can see things a
little bit more nicely.
I can see that on top, I have
a navigation bar with my two
pages, my Hello, Penguins!
page with my analysis
and also my About page.
And they're automatically
linked to that.
And basically, clicking
on the name of the website
takes me back to my home page.
Let me show you one
other feature that's
actually a newer feature of
Quarto, starting with 1.3.
Let's go ahead, and for this
index page, add another format.
So I am going to say that I
do want an HTML with default
options, but I also want a PDF
of the same document as well.
And let's go ahead and render
the website one more time.
And if I take a look
at my output now,
we can see that not
only do I have the HTML
file on my website, but I have
an ability to actually download
a PDF version of my document.
So if you are creating websites
but you have artifacts in there
that you would like people to
be able to download as PDFs,
I think this is a really
handy tool for doing so.
So we've gone from a single
document to a slide deck,
to a website, but all of this
is living on my computer.
To wrap things up,
let's talk about how
do I get this and make
it available to others.
Obviously, I could use version
control to get things to GitHub
and publish from there,
but another option
is to use Quarto Pub.
So I am going to now
go to my Terminal.
And in my terminal, I am going
to type publish or quarto
publish.
And when I hit
quarto publish, it
gives me some options for
where I might want to publish.
I'll say that I want to
publish to Quarto Pub.
I have previously
linked my account here.
So if this is your
first time doing it,
it's going to ask you to
actually create and link
an account.
But yes, I do want to.
And I do want to authorize this.
The site name
comes from the name
that I gave it in
my Quarto file,
so that was welcome to
Quarto, and has simply created
a version of it without spaces.
And I'm going to hit Enter.
And we can see
that it's rendering
my page one more time.
And it is now shooting this--
once it's rendered,
publishing it on Quarto Pub.
All right, and here we go.
We can actually see
that my page has
been published on Quarto Pub.
This is the view for
me to manage the site.
I can delete the
site, for example,
or change its Slug if I want.
But I can also--
I'm also provided
a direct link to it
that I can share with others.
So I have the simple
website that I
have created with the two
pages now published on the web
and ready to share with others.
I hope you found this
introduction useful.
And what I will do
at the end of this
is commit and push all of my
changes to a GitHub repository
where you can simply pick
things up from where I left off
and continue your
exploration of Quarto.